[Music]
foreign
it is the courage and the determination
of the party leaders and the people of
Northern Ireland who have been Central
in making this opportunity for peace
happen it's been reached because
everybody was willing to compromise
everybody has moved a little and as a
result everyone can be a winner as a
result of this agreement
[Music]
gonna show them how all bloody conflicts
can be transcended through new
ship
I am European as well as Irish
[Music]
and what we all have to learn is what
the people of Europe learned and we are
learning in Northern Ireland difference
whether it's your race or your religion
or your nationality is an accident took
birth and it's not something we should
be engaged in Conflict about it's
something we should respect
I think the Good Friday agreement is the
basic underpinning of of the peace that
we all enjoy I think it's made a big
change I think it has made a difference
if it was to go away there probably it
might be a difference and it might go
back to like what it was which is quite
scary
[Music]
we'll just need to move forward and make
sure history doesn't repeat itself and
it's sort of a foundation for how to
move forward as well
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
there are a few examples in European
history of a people's peace agreement
such as the 1998 Belfast Good Friday
agreement brokered by the people of all
of Northern Ireland aided by the
government of the United Kingdom and
Ireland and supported by the European
Union and the United States of America
endorsed by people on both parts of the
island of Ireland agreeing to lift
borders that divided communities
defended by the people during
post-brexit uncertainty when the
importance of the agreement became even
more relevant time and again over the
years the European Union and this
Parliament reiterated its unwavering
support for the hard-earned peace
process on the island of Ireland
going forward
the 2023 Windsor framework lays down
arrangements for the protocol on Ireland
and Northern Ireland
it will Charter a new way forward
towards ending post-brexit uncertainties
dear Europeans the European peace
project was born From the Ashes of world
wars
it held the ambition of bringing peoples
together in the hope of lasting peace
and prosperity
Nobel Peace Prize Laureate John Hume
said in this house and as we just heard
in the video we all have to learn
is what peoples of Europe learned
difference is not something we should be
engaged in Conflict about it is
something we should respect
Europe is a place of reconciliation
where everyone's voice counts and this
European Parliament is a place where
peoples of Europe have come together
setting aside past resentment to talk
and to listen
the transcripts of the dialogue held in
this Parliament between former members
of the European Parliament from Northern
Ireland is evidence of that willingness
to set aside animosity and that
willingness to talk
and to listen and this house evidently
provided a platform for this dialogue
for peace
25 years ago members of the European
Parliament welcomed the Belfast Good
Friday agreement with warm and heartfelt
admiration and with gratitude
because Northern Ireland's people
reminded all Europeans of the
fundamental values on which Europe's
peace and prosperity lay
over 25 years of Peace people's daily
lives in Northern Ireland have been
transformed they no longer live with the
threats of violence all Island
Corporation is everywhere to be seen and
yet
this Belfast Good Friday agreement still
needs nurturing issues relating to
social justice and Civic Corporation
were Central to the agreement
civil activists and promoters of Peace
in Northern Ireland know that commitment
to civil and political rights is key
the agreement restored self-government
to Northern Ireland on the basis of
power sharing and all of us here believe
in parliamentary democracy and we will
do what we can to promote that concept
and I look forward to being able to
exchange ideas with parliamentarians in
Northern Ireland and as that young woman
in the video said if the Good Friday
agreement were to go I it might probably
might be quite scary and that is why we
are marking the 25th anniversary of the
Belfast Good Friday agreement in this
house of European democracy today
because preserving peace is also
important and listening to all sides
respectfully is key
[Applause]
thank you
I give the floor now to the president of
the European Council dear Child Michelle
deflor is yours
we will take points of order later
[Applause]
May the employees of the parliament of
the commission ladies and gentlemen dear
friends
Sandra parks
in the heart of North Belfast
during the troubles this park was sliced
in two by a wall like a dark star
riding through the Green Landscape
a peace wall it was called
because like the dozens of other
peacefuls erected over four decades it
was built to stop the fighting
this Wars divided two communities that
shared the same language but they
couldn't use that language to talk to
each other for decades they thought
for decades they checked their children
apart
ladies and gentlemen
25 years ago the Good Friday agreement
was signed a remarkable achievement that
took real political leadership Visionary
leaders that did not fear compromise and
it brought the cycle of Decades of
violence and a certain peace stability
and Reconciliation
disagreements took 700 days of
negotiations by men and women of Courage
a launched with determination of our
American friends the UK and Ireland's
membership in the EU and Twitter
industrial Market provided common ground
on which to build a lasting Peace by
bringing people together and by removing
the physical economic and psychological
barriers between people
the EU was crucial to reach the Good
Friday agreement and has been essential
to ensure its survival throughout all
these years in fact the Good Friday
agreement also Echoes back another major
moment in history 41 years earlier the
Treaty of Rome the founding Treaty of
our European Union that aspired after
the tragedy of World War II to build up
a spirit that unites and to draw down
Borders The Divide
peace in Ireland and European
integration are staked in the same ideal
exploding the richness of diversity
rather than throwing division The Good
Friday agreement it's also an important
reminder
that we are all capable of feeling
strong emotion and connection to more
than one nation this is not something to
fear multiple identities are part of
human nature and you should keep this in
mind across our regions that are on
their own journeys of Peace
reconciliation and cooperation within
our big European family
ladies and gentlemen
the peace wall in Alexandra Park
today but this symbol of division now
has a date with families Crossing
between the two sides what was once a
symbol of fear and separation is now
today a sign of Peace progress and
common future
tolerance respect and diversity this was
the spirit and energy that forced The
Good Friday agreement 25 years ago and
this is the spirit and energy we still
need today to protect these heart-wound
genes and to build a lasting peace for
the children on the island of Ireland
and everywhere in Europe I thank you
thank you very much president Michelle I
now give the floor to the president of
the European commission Ursula
Wonderland you have the floor
honorable members
25 years ago
the leaders of Northern Ireland Ireland
and the UK made the impossible come true
for years
every attempt to broker piece had failed
at Easter in 1998
when a new proposal was put on the table
the talks were once again on the verge
of collapse
felt like Northern Ireland could return
to violence
it took the courage and the vision
of some extraordinary leaders to crush
cross the finish line
but this success was not only made at
the negotiating table and the places
such as Hillsborough Castle
at the time
outside the castle
a small crowd of school children had
gathered
with their parents
and their teachers
they came from Catholic and Protestant
families
and They Carried balloons and signs with
two simple words
peace
please
it was a stark reminder of what was at
stake in those negotiations not only
different identities ideals and
Allegiance but the future of the
children in Northern Ireland
The Good Friday Belfast agreement has
delivered on the simple demand of those
children
with 25 years of peace
25 years of possibilities
so today we celebrate Brave leaders like
John Shoon and David Trimble who came
from opposing sides and ended up sharing
a Noble Peace Prize
but we also celebrate all the peace
loving people of Ireland and Northern
Ireland the unsung heroes of the Good
Friday Belfast agreement
The Good Friday Belfast agreement not
only ended 30 years of the troubles
it also opened a new era of
cooperation
as the first line of the agreement says
it is and I quote the opportunity for a
new beginning end of quote
for the two communities and the two
islands and it was indeed
a new beginning
in these 25 years
Northern Ireland has taken giant steps
forward also thanks to European support
checkpoints have been replaced with
sport venues and schools
just recently a wall was torn down in
West Belfast to make room for an
eu-funded Community Center
of course many other walls still stand
not all wounds have healed
while a peace deal can be signed with a
stroke of a pen reconciliation
is always the work of generations
but as one of Northern Ireland's
greatest Sons Van Morrison said
and I quote
for the healing
go on with the dreaming end of quote
and this is what makes the Good Friday
Belfast agreement so important
beyond the latter
and the spirit there's a promise of a
better future for all the people of
Northern Ireland
sadly
the wax referendum raised new challenges
for both the letter and the spirit and
the promise of the goat Friday Belfast
agreement
since 2016 everyone in our Union has
worked hard
to avoid that brexit became an obstacle
on the path of reconciliation on the
island of Ireland
this journey was never smooth
but our goal
is now finally in sight
as a set of joint Solutions under with
under the withdrawal agreement
The Winds of framework
continues to support the letter
the spirit and the promise of the Good
Friday Belfast agreement
it preserves our precious single Market
it preserves Northern Ireland's integral
place in the United Kingdom's internal
Market
and crucially
it preserves the foundations of Peace by
avoiding a hard border on the island of
Ireland
and I want to thank the British prime
minister Rishi sunak for his can-do
approach
together
we are staying true to the Good Friday
promise that never again will there be a
hard border on the island of Ireland
thank you
all of this is an immense opportunity
for the people of Northern Ireland
they will have the same food on their
supermark shelves and the same access to
medicines as in the rest of the UK
and they will continue to have unique
access to the single Market that is the
most powerful driver of growth all
across our continent
an island will benefit from this
whether they identify as Irish British
Northern Irish European
or a combination of all this
so I can only hope
that rationality will once again Prevail
like just like it did 25 years ago
honorable members thanks to the Good
Friday Belfast agreement there's a whole
generation of young people in Northern
Ireland who were born and raised in
peace
who will not accept to go back to the
problems of the fast past who just want
to live a full life
they understand better than anyone else
that peace and prosperity
were not achieved once and for all on
that Good Friday agreement a quarter of
a century ago
peace and prosperity
must be rewind day after day
generation after generation
so today
we don't just gather for commemoration
but for a new commitment
to keep working for reconciliation in
Northern Ireland in spite of all
setbacks
for the next 25 years and Way Beyond
the UK may have left our Union but peace
Remains the European promise long-live
Europe manifest
very much we now give the floor for a
round of political group speakers
starting with the Epp group David
McAllister for two minutes each
seats 249.
okay
Madam president ladies and gentlemen
dear colleagues
just rightly described by our free
presidents the troubles in Northern
Ireland were one of the darkest chapters
in recent European history
for the longest time
deep historic Rifts between unionists
and nationalists made any negotiations
for lasting peace seemingly impossible
with the 25th anniversary of the Good
Friday Belfast agreement we are
celebrating a historic development that
remains essential to peace and indeed
reconciliation in Northern Ireland
dear colleagues the true test of
political leadership comes
when it takes courage to lead against
popular belief
and the peace process on the island of
Ireland has known more than one
courageous political leader
The Good Friday Belfast agreement
demonstrates it is possible to achieve
great good in politics
ever since 1998 we as European Union we
have worked alongside our UK and Irish
Partners to implement exactly this
agreement it was exactly in this spirit
that we conducted the brexit
negotiations amid the rise of old
questions of sovereignty and national
identity preventing a hard board on the
island of Ireland was and is an
essential priority for the European
Union
particularly in times of serious
geopolitical challenges a stable
cooperation with the United Kingdom is
so crucial
much more unites us than divides us
and is just mentioned by the commission
president The Windsor framework with
this Windsor framework we have found
practical solutions to the challenges in
the implementation of the protocol in
Ireland and Northern Ireland while
maintaining the Integrity of our EU
single Market
yes indeed The Windsor framework offers
a United Way Forward but it also honors
the historic achievements we are
commemorating today together with our UK
Partners letters use this momentum to
walk the talk and to implement the
solutions reached on paper thank you
thank you very much
[Applause]
on behalf of the snd group to Pedro
Silva Pereira
thank you share our presidents
for the last 25 years
The Good Friday Belfast agreement
delivered on its promise of peace and
stability for Northern Ireland
and peace is not a minor issue as we all
know when we should recall today more
than ever
25 years of Peace in Northern Ireland is
a remarkable political achievement
that indeed deserves proper celebration
so that we all can praise the progress
made and the parties involved can
renovate their commitments in working
together for a peaceful a peaceful
future in Northern Ireland
carefully negotiated and successfully
concluded in 1988 under a labor
government led by Tony Blair with a full
engagement of remarkable Irish political
leaders the good Pride agreement made
all the difference for the people in
Northern Ireland instead of violence
peace instead of Confrontation dialogue
compromise and cooperation instead of
struggles for Domination and power
across Community power sharing
challenging resentment and disbelief The
Good Friday agreement worked for the
last 25 years and still sets the
framework for new Ambitions for the
future of the island of Ireland the
European Europe the European Union is
not just a mere spectator of the Good
Friday agreement it is an Engaged party
in this International agreement fully
committed in delivering its promises in
all these parts
that is why it was always clear for the
European Union that despite brexit and
while safeguarding the Integrity of the
European Union single Market we had to
keep the promise of not having again an
art border between the Republic of
Ireland and Northern Ireland and this
was since the beginning the goal of the
commonly agreed Northern Ireland
protocol as it is now the goal of the
recently agreed Windsor framework
for us it is clear that time is come to
turn the page of this absurd
confrontation against the EU
and more than that
we need immediately to see
power sharing coming back to Northern
Ireland
and so that after 25 years of Peace we
can build 25 years of prosperity for the
people in Northern Avenue thank you
thank you very much vice president Silva
Pereira
and now I give the floor to Barry
Andrews on behalf of the renew Europe
group
president metzola president Michelle
president bondoline and colleagues
today's ceremony is very very welcome
and sometimes we undersell the eu's role
in sustaining peace in Northern Ireland
a role I would argue is even more
significant than that of the United
States
the peace in Northern Ireland is in my
view one of the European Union's
greatest achievements
it was the EU that provided the
financial support through structural
funds and the peace program
it was the EU and its single Market that
made borders less relevant
it was the EU that provided the context
and arena for closer relations that
otherwise would have been impossible
in May 2007 Ian Paisley a former MEP
contacted the Irish government to
request that Jose Manuel barroso would
come to Belfast to be in attendance at
Paisley's first official meeting with
Martin McGinnis
presence of the EU was visually
important
to what otherwise would have been an
awkward moment for Paisley
and it was the EU that provided the
symbolism of Peace building as the 1952
coal and steel treaty aimed at quote
building a broader and deeper Community
among people's lung divided by Bloody
conflict end quote
fdlp MEP and Nobel Prize winner John
Hume used this language as a framework
to ensure that the EU would play a role
much to the irritation of the UK
government
however ultimately the greatest credit
goes to the people of Northern Ireland
and now after an era of Peace 25 years
later the tantalizing prize of
prosperity awaits for the Next
Generation the EU must continue to play
a role and in my view support reform of
the Good Friday agreement presently the
cost of staying out of the executive is
too low and for too long bad behavior
has been rewarded
while the brexit negotiations have been
agonizing and in this respect I'd like
to pay tribute to both Michelle barnier
and marosefkovic for all of their
perseverance
The Good Friday agreement and the eu's
role in it can only be properly honored
by staying the course and maintaining
support for a speedy Return of the
executive and the dawn of a new era in
Northern Ireland thank you
thank you very much
Mr Andrews I give the floor now to the
co-president of the green group Terrier
Dear Presidents dear colleagues today we
are celebrating the 25th anniversary of
the Good Friday agreement The Good
Friday agreement came after long
conflict 3 500 people had lost their
lives in decades marked by Violence by
insecurity and by hatred this agreement
is a symbol of committed peace building
and still 25 years later we acknowledge
the hard work the political will and the
commitment that was put into making it
happen by so many people
colleagues we all know that brexit has
shaken the political situation in
Northern Ireland and made many of the
question that still need resolving more
difficult and this is not going to go
away for a while but with the Windsor
framework the European Union and the UK
have recently shown that constructive
negotiations based on trust and
understanding have good outcome even in
difficult situations and we will
continue to do everything in our power
to secure peace in Northern Ireland and
to support the Good Friday agreement but
let's also never forget p this is not
only the absence of armed conflict
safeguarding fundamental rights of all
citizens is a crucial part of a
sustainable peace and that is why the
European convention on human rights has
played such an important role for peace
building in Northern Ireland and the
Good Friday agreement and that is why
defending the European convention on
human rights is absolutely crucial
especially now that we see it being put
under attack
colleagues the European Union was built
on promoting peace on the ruins of
violent conflict millions of people came
together
so let us not only remember the great
effort it took to achieve peace and the
Good Friday agreement but let's let's
build on the spirit for the future for a
peaceful adjust and a democratic Island
United Kingdom and Europe built on
understanding on trust and on human
rights thank you very much thank you
very much Miss Reinke
and now on behalf of the ECR group I
give the floor to head bourgeois
Etters colleague presidents ladies and
gentlemen thank you very much after
years of
and to unrest and violence The Good
Friday agreement has now been
providing for peace and democracy for
over 25 years democracy is a means to
achieve political goals
What followed from this was stability
with power sharing between once sworn
enemies
brexit however once again brought unrest
and tensions with it
at any cost we have to make sure that
the Good Friday agreement be eroded
after a long and protracted discussion
it is finally been achieved to get
through the Windsor framework an
agreement concerning the Northern
Ireland protocol so thank you to all the
people concerned and negotiators as well
who 25 years later once again have
managed to surpass themselves
the political will and the
guidance and Leadership from the
negotiators of the Good Friday agreement
have given a whole generation the
opportunity to grow up in peace and
prosperity the essence of what the EU
has meant for us for 75 years my group
honestly hopes that in the spirit of the
Good Friday agreement were as a
cherished Legacy of reconciliation all
the parties concerned will
take the New Windsor framework as a
possibility to allow citizens and
companies to have a prosperous future in
Northern Ireland as an impetus for the
Democratic in
institutions of Northern Ireland to work
once again as they should and as a
watershed moment for a renewed positive
cooperation between the UK and the EU
and hopefully that will spread out to
more areas than the case is at the
moment thank you
now on behalf of the ID group Marco
company
thank you president well on the 10th of
April 1998 I was a young
activist
I was following the Irish issue
passionately
and uh
with the Good Friday agreement I learned
a lesson which I've carried with me ever
since
which
relates to the need to try and
understand
the reasons of those on the other side
when you're dealing with a political
issue I mean in this case we're talking
about an agreement
that add to the LEDs to the end of
Decades of bloodshed
and
that's why I would like to emphasize
what Christian churches have said
in recent days because both sides used
the church to feed the conflict and so I
think that aspect is important
the agreement has shown itself to be
Fragile on occasion over the last 25
years but
this has been the result of debate or
political disagreements no one talks
about weapons nowadays
but in political debate and
in democracy you have to ensure that
debates remain political in nature I
think the 25th anniversary comes at a
good time now
because as the president of the
commission recalled
the United Kingdom has come to an
agreement with Brussels which will
Foster trade and development and I hope
that
here in the coming weeks and months we
can
have the appropriate attitude vis-a-vis
London and we hope that the Hostile
attitudes that are sometimes seen will
be attenuated
hopefully
we have learned also from what we're
seeing elsewhere in the world
that uh basing ourselves on
International organizations on
cooperating internationally for example
to fight terrorism
we can work together and
achieve things
events are the result of historical
times every era has its protagonists and
its men and women who ensure that
political objectives are achieved and
that's why I believe that in our work as
elected representatives it's important
to base ourselves on those who 25 years
ago in the United Kingdom and in Ireland
were able to work for peace putting an
end to Decades of conflict
so please let's all be up to those who
preceded us the men and women who made
our continent continent great those who
achieved goals that related to Freedom
peace and prosperity right across Europe
thank you
I give the floor now on behalf of the
left group to Chris McManus appreciate
the floor
president house celebrates the Good
Friday agreement and the 25 years of
peace and progress it has brought to the
island of Ireland
this historic agreement put in place a
new constitutional framework in the
north of Ireland that would finally
guarantee equality justice and human
rights
The Good Friday agreement is a peace
process and a political process it's a
living breeding document it is a
framework which guarantees that the
people of Ireland North and South will
decide whether to unite
or whether the north remains tied to
Britain
My Hope Is that within this decade the
people will be asked to be part of a new
Ireland a modern forward-looking society
based on peace equality and social
progress within the European Union
the future of the whole island is one
where we work together for the benefit
of all
over the years most of the problems have
stemmed from Tory governments failure to
act as the agreement says they should
which rigorous impartiality a continued
failure to uphold the agreement
consistently taking one political side
does nobody any favors it merely delays
the progress that we know must happen
to those who reject the very principles
of the Good Friday agreement I have a
simple message
equality benefits everyone we should be
able to move Beyond seeing our neighbors
as our enemies attempts to deny rights
to different groups of people marriage
equality Reproductive Rights language
rights damage the economic and social
cohesion of the north we should all be
working together for the benefit of all
the people which is why the executive in
the north must be established without
delay
building an economy that benefits
everyone building a society that works
for all where no one is Left Behind
that's why it is important that this
house celebrates the 25th anniversary
and I have no doubt that this house and
the EU will continue to play an
important role for the next 25 years as
a good Friday agreement about embarks
upon its next chapter Karama
[Music]
thank you very much Mr McManus thank you
to all the colleagues
we now move to the agenda of this
current plenary